bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au mwc
à barcelone et on va parler des sony
xperia x2 et x2 propane
[Musique]
le sony xperia x10 est de succès de
sonic seria xperia x1 un produit qui a
vraiment été revus et corrigés notamment
en termes de design alors il ya plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités qui sont super
intéressante et ce qui le premier point
qui est vraiment frappant c'est le
design c'est à dire que beaucoup de
personnes reproché à ceux dits au niveau
de leur gamme xperia d'avoir toujours un
design un peu old school qui
correspondaient pas aux standards
actuels
et c'est un peu leur point faible autant
il ya plein de personnes qui
reconnaissait que leur fonctionnalité
était super que la qualité des caméras
soient à l'avant ou à l'arrière était
vraiment bien le traitement logiciel top
mais le design pas terrible et là avec
les xperia x2 exode de contact ils vont
plus loin ils ont revu un peu leur copie
et c'est vraiment intéressant alors en
plus d'un design qui est effectivement
repenser une ergonomie un produit qui
est sympa qui se tient bien qui est dans
les standards actuels de ce qu'on peut
retrouver un produit qui est vraiment
sympa qu'il va plus loin en termes de
photos et de vidéos vous pouvez filmer
en 4k mais en 4k hdr j'ai vu une
comparaison ce qui était vraiment très
impressionnant parce qu'il ya une
différence entre le sony xperia x2 et le
xz-1 la vraie différence se fait
vraiment au niveau de l'éclat des
couleurs on voit qu'avec le x2 vous a
découvert qu'ils sont quand même
beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus saturés alors que le fait
que le xz-1 vous avez des couleurs qui
sont un peu plus pâle même si ça va
également mais c'est un peu plus pâle
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment beaucoup plus flatteur d'avoir
du hdr sur l'a4 qu'à côté slow motion
ils vont plus loin avec le ixe et
d'endesa effectivement introduit le slow
motion à 960 images par seconde qui a
été repris par samsung
au niveau de son galaxy s le galaxy s 9
plus là où samsung fait du super slow
mots en 960 images par seconde en hd
c'est à dire en 1280 par 720 pixels
le sony xperia x12 et x2 ultra vont plus
loin ils font non seulement du super
slow moore 960 images par seconde mais
surtout ils le font en full hd en 1920
par 1080 pixels ce qui fait que si vous
êtes créateur de contenu du film et vous
voulez atteindre publier des vidéos sur
youtube ou sur d'autres plateformes en
full hd
vous pourrez le faire vous avez pas
besoin d'avoir un 720p vous allez
regarder dans l'image et rajouter un peu
de pixels vous allez pouvoir la voir
directement nativement et ça c'est
vraiment bien donc on voit qu'en plus
l'année dernière avoir sorti le super ce
nouveau en premier par rapport aux
autres
las de se faire rattraper par samsung
ils vont encore plus loin en le sortant
full hd et ça c'est vraiment un point
positif tout écran on retrouve un écran
hdr 5,7 pouces au format 18 ne vienne
c'est vraiment bien c'est vrai que les
couleurs se tiennent la luminosité bien
c'est un produit la qualité est au
rendez vous j'ai pas du sud ce côté là
sur le ixe aide parce que sur le
business de compact vous avez un écran
qui est plus petit qu'un écran de 5
pouces forcément ces modèles compacts
une autre fonctionnalité qui est
nouvelle qui est sympa c'est le
dynamique par immolation système les
vibrations dynamique vous regardez un
film il ya de l'action ça bouge
votre smartphone vivre en cadence par
rapport à ce que vous avez à l'écran or
sur un film d'action votre téléphone
mains libres et vous pouvez régler vous
n'êtes pas obligé de la voir moi j'ai
trouvé ça c'est sympa ça me branche pas
d'avoir un téléphone qui vibre tout
temps dans mes mains je préfère regarder
un film être en immersion mais il ya des
personnes qui comme dans les jeux vidéos
avec des manettes vibrante et moi on
bien cette fonctionnalité est apprécié
aurait effectivement que leur téléphone
ça t'a dit dre super fort lors c'est une
action qui qui est vraiment prenante
pourquoi pas moi personnellement c'est
pas un truc qui me tente
en tout cas ces nouveaux side of 5
mérite d'exister c'est plutôt sympa une
fonctionnalité qui est très sympa c'est
le scan de visages de scan 3d on va
mobiliser votre visage en trois
dimensions alors pourquoi faire
on me dira beaurains
un visage mode et en trois dimensions
vous pouvez effectivement l'imprimer sur
une imprimante 3d ça peut être rigolo
vous faire un petit souvenir ahmed sans
votre étagère mais non seulement vous
allez pouvoir april utilisés sur les
réseaux sociaux et c'est ça qui est
sympa vous pourrez par exemple partager
votre visage remodelé en trois
dimensions sur facebook alors ces
gadgets mais c'est plutôt sympa et c'est
là où on voit un peu tout la la
précision de jag la caméra d'avoir une
excellente caméra permet effectivement
de capter votre visage les différents
rôles ya des visages dans les moindre
précision dans moins de détails donc ça
s'est vraiment bien et en plus la
capacité logiciel de vous modélisez un
visage vous faire un mapping en trois
dimensions et ça c'est vraiment bien ça
montre effectivement la capacité de sony
a proposé d' une nouvelle fonctionnalité
à innover et pas uniquement s'arrêter je
dirais aux fonctions vidéos photos un
peu plus standard a grandi mais c'est un
produit qui a de la recharge par
induction il a bien évidemment une
certification ip68 sur le ixe aide de
vous trouver un gorilla glass 5 à
l'avant et à l'arrière donc un produit
qui est robuste qui ne devrait pas
craindre les shops attention à tous les
chocs mais c'est vrai qu'en tout cas les
gorilla glass sont vraiment reconnue
pour être vraiment des verts d'extrême
bonne qualité il tourne avec un stop
dragonne mais c'est quoi comme 1 845 qui
offre 30 % de performances en plus par
rapport au ixe et d'un côté stockage il
a 64 giga de ram extensible jusqu'à 400
giga avec une carte microsd et tourne
sous l'os android 8.0 oreo à l'arrière
il a une caméra 19 mégapixels avec une
ouverture 2.0 et l avant une caméra 5
mégapixels avec l'ouverture de deux
points 2 à voir lors de phases de tests
si la caméra arrière en 19 mai à pixels
ne va pas souffrir un peu de faible
luminosité avec une ouverture f 2.0
à voir à tester ultérieurement et vous
avez 4 gigas de ram sur ces appareils
quel drame vont vraiment être optimiste
parce qu'au niveau logiciel vous avez
l'application smart cleaner qui va
vraiment devenir optimiser votre xperia
pour qu'ils aillent plus vite pour qu'il
ait de bonnes performances et que vous
perdez pas trop de place en terme de
stockage
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est plutôt bien
pensé la différence avec le ixe et de
compacts avec les deux compacts vous
n'avez pas un gorille église à l'arrière
vous avez un d'eau en plastique
forcément c'est le produit qui coûte
moins cher il ya forcément un aspect que
beaucoup moins premium
il a un écran 5 pouces mustian en termes
de design élégant on n'a rien à lui
reprocher la grande différence est
effectivement il n'aura pas les
vibrations dynamique lorsque vous allez
regarder une vidéo et vous allez pas
avoir de recharge par induction mais
mise à part ça il fait alors gorilla
glass deux à l'arrière il ya des
craintes de plus petits il se tient
plutôt bien
si vous voulez un modèle un peu plus
compact un peu plus petits un peu moins
cher c'est plutôt pas mal
on l'a peu pour les grandes
fonctionnalités les grandes nouveautés
de ce chez sony avec le xperia x2 et x2
compact ya effectivement aussi plein
d'autres choses des accessoires faisait
par exemple un casque et vous permet
d'écouter votre musique mais un casque
qui vous garde ouvert sur
l'environnement c'est pas un casque
fermé
l'intérêt c'est effectivement vous avez
votre musique vous avez une bonne
qualité sonore lorsque quelqu'un vous
parle vous avez une alerte vous
l'entendez vous n'êtes pas dans votre
bulle
bon c'est un petit détail mais ça fait
partie un peu de l'écosystème complet de
chez sony il ya pas mal de choses c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant parce qu'on
voit c'est que sony innove et bien
vraiment une position qui est très forte
aussi au niveau des photophones on voit
que samsung était très très loin cette
année avec son galaxy s 9 ses galaxy s 9
et xps 9 plus pardon avec une ouverture
variable très clairement que c'est
xperia x2 et ces deux compacts seront
très bons en bonne luminosité avec une
excellente caméra souriait toujours été
très très bon au niveau de la photo
j'arrive au plus haut niveau la vidéo 4k
hdr maintenant par faible luminosité je
demande à voir
je demande ça va être toujours aussi bon
c'est le point d'interrogation à
vérifier et avoir plus tardivement vous
ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez ce nouveau design
de
est-ce que c'est experia x10 et de
compaq pourrez vous tenter est-ce que
vous aidez se dit est ce que vous
trouvez qu'ils vont dans le bon sens qui
vont se renouveler
est ce que vous aimez la qualité photo
de tous ses appareils par kim à tous
sans commentaire parce que je trouve que
c'est vraiment un truc hyper intéressant
on voit cette année qu'en 2018 on va
encore plus loin au niveau des
photophones et y avoir un vrai challenge
une vraie compétition au niveau la
qualité photo sur les smartphones on va
plus loin au niveau de l'intelligence
artificielle là dessus rien chez sony
pour l'instant de cadre de ce que j'ai
vu j'ai rien vu de particulier sur ses
expériences et des objets de compacts
affaire à suivre
merci beaucoup marqué moi tout sans
commentaire cette année c'est déjà les
pousse à vous abonner on reste connectés
parce que la chaux mwc il ya énormément
de choses le temps se gâte
il fait un peu moins beau c'est dommage
on va voir ce dont on mange des tapas en
vol la sangria et il fait beau la fait
pas beau tant pis merci beaucoup je vous
invite à rester connectés à vous abonner
venir plein de nouveautés plein de
contenus à venir ce qui perd cool autres
soyez sages
à bientôt je vous embrasse correspondent
chaouk
[Musique]